[Music]
[Music]
hello testing testing
oh I think we had sound now David it's
good I mean Persia yeah
I sweaty 20 man this is how exactly
starting is the starting launch pad so
you missed our amazing intro the first
time yeah we went off but yeah
anywho I had realized I put the names
backwards and I was like oh snap
well this is Persia I'm David David and
today we are playing some call of duty
modern warfare which obviously has been
out but on recently I think I was like
31st or something like that they just
dropped grind mode it's official it's a
bright there says new in everything so
we're gonna play some games of that I'm
gonna pray we have a lot of Christmas
noobs online so I can at least get some
kills that would be amazing and Happy
New Year
yes Happy New Year you guys it's alright
take two to four twenty twenty right
there there you go oh my god I love this
so much everything is going right so
right anywho what do you guys do over
New Year's switch seats but I got a man
the station yeah she's playing yeah I'm
not trying to throw David into the deep
end of all the stream set up here I have
a lot of buttons to keep track of not
just the ones on the controller is the
switch good yeah if you think about
Nintendo switch I would say yes yeah
every every consoles awesome TBH like
play what you want yeah you play on the
PS Vita dude great beta dude more and
more power to you are having
fantastic starts can try your pings
pretty low though right under 25
nice wish I had that at oh you gotta be
a glass-half-full that Grayson yeah I
hope you have the the team chat muted or
whatever we don't wanna oh I know is
there a way to do that from this I
honestly don't remember it probably be
in your settings just pray but it might
yeah let's just pray it might be funny
Happy New Year lightning vortex and poor
Peto
and everybody else in the chat thanks
for joining us by the way
oh you guys are awesome alright alright
I can't remember if I've played on this
map or not but it doesn't matter they're
gonna get destroyed we're gonna Caliph
you don't know the grind is its a mix
between Kill Confirmed and heart point
and you got a basically a rack of all
these tags
I'm not leveled up to where I want to be
yet so all of my classes are kind of
booty but it's alright we're gonna make
it work riot stick to me in the lobby oh
right right go for a nuke you got it bro
I do remember this map okay oh yeah with
all the apartments maybe I don't I
thought there was another Holly all good
Molotov out Jack's this is a pretty
stage though it is
[Music]
okay okay we're gonna confusion it's
fine let me just drop off these three
spicy tags oh I feel like I went to the
furthest one possible possibly it's all
good I just want to do it once yeah oh
yeah because they mentioned a lot about
you have to have strategy and you know
try to have someone who's running the
tags for you while you're defending them
and stuff like that oh yeah
but now it makes sense why is because
you can't just run in there and drop
them all at once right lord solar ass
what's drying drying it's like a Kill
Confirmed meets hardline I got every
kills gonna drop these dog tags
you got to collect the dog tags whether
if it's your teammates who died or the
enemy and then you go to these sections
- oh I know it's a gold mine air strike
Oh
right on the money that's actually a
good point on because sometimes when I
get air strikes it's hard for me to kind
of know someone's gonna be an Elaine or
not
yeah just like oh there's attack just
drop right oh how did I know someone was
gonna be there
use point man perk for easy score
streets on this mode not the one that
reduces the requirement by like the one
or something I think so that's I will
look into it
hopefully I'm leveled up enough I'm only
a twenty four right now which feels bad
that's more than me I'm currently
playing on xbox but at home I would ps4
is okay so this map I don't think of as
big as I'm imagining and city knows it's
fairly oh yeah oh yeah that's another
thing that I actually like about my
boyfriend is like huh you can claim
stuff I'm in it's not as like fluid as
maybe an apex or something but yeah it
has some verticality without introducing
like jetpacks and stuff Jordan asks how
are you guys enjoying this so far Manny
we've been at it for a solid five
minutes and it's been it's been killer
yeah I played a ton of the beta yeah
down well there's a lot of hype with
when the game came out right like both
for people who played the OGE
trilogy for modern warfare and a bunch
of you know the newer generation of
gamers for getting their hands on
the yearly release that it is known as
Cod oh shoot gyros asking is there a
switch approach NASA this couple times
you don't know and twenty men
anything could happen yeah I could have
a turn
Tyra's also have since you have a good
Christmas I shouldn't people right you
need uh you need a bit of a handcuff
something distracted like counter-strike
oh thank goodness there's no friendly
mark says who's the better out of the
two of you owe me my mom's not playing
it's like I don't even need the blaze of
you very for me I feel where Katie's
would come out to a solid even the one
Oh at least maybe most of the time but
it depends
you're straight though oh I forgot it's
like this oh you have to like look at
there
[Music]
[Music]
Oh sauna the corner of my eye I wasn't
sure are we gonna play dragon won't seek
a crack oh yeah absolutely
I'm I'm personally stoked a f4 dragon
Lizzy I love I tried this style on it
what's wrong I'm not that good you would
have hit him if you actually pulled off
the 360 there you know yeah exactly
that's what you get extra damage when
you do the phrase like a wind-up oh dang
oh dang such a thing they're like
camping yeah and you kill I'm cool but
then you don't get the tag turn it right
over there all right ring and be
stealthy you hear what that's just
kidding since I questions when you camp
in this mood yeah you can't you don't
get credit you don't get no tags you're
not delivering yeah there you go there
you awesome yeah let's go now my best
performance but you know what that was a
warm-up yeah
brings up the streets into scorestreaks
so pick Oh hold up let me just see if I
have that perk you know appointment Oh
No level 49 all right we're gonna get
level 49 right now just but that does
sound like it's like purchasing levels
yeah I know right
I mean free bundle what got a little
chameleon scanner son you know I've
always really liked skins in this game I
remember like the older cards when you
didn't like create your own little icon
those were fun oh I remember those there
was a lot of not safe for work that's
like unavoidable when you put a feature
like that in a game yeah you just you
know you could never play like when
you're a teenager you can never play Cod
I'm like the family TV ever back in
those days like I didn't know how to
like mute stuff so I'm just like going
into spawns and people are like
screaming dropping just the worst cuss
words ever man like it was those were a
time it's got its own like nostalgic
charm though it's weird I don't know I
don't know how to explain it
alright we got this oh wait for a wild
second I thought you were running and
doing your blood at the same time
multitask all right there
z yes I'm an old school player you still
drop shots let's do this
it's so funny when we played the beta on
the stream so many people are like who
drop shots anymore and I'm like me and
especially in destiny man people will be
like tea bagging while they're shooting
to throw you off
and I always hate that all right I have
a better feel for what this man man I
feel like the colors are so weird the
kind of muted ah yeah yeah maybe in my
settings this is the same map we just
played yeah
gotta love that rotation I gots I came
for that same angle so what did I play
during Christmas ask Chris alright it's
gonna sound so silly but this new mobile
game came out called
oh it's not called it's called like
Simon ball pro 2 or something like that
and it's basically a phone game where a
detective gives you like this victims
phone and you gotta like solve the case
by going through her phone and her
social media and like finding out
details it's actually really really cool
just stung them read as you deliver your
oh wait I didn't pick it up that's like
the worst part it's him it's him I know
it is delivered I've contributed to the
team Oh God I heard shuffling I was
complaining to you just now before we
started the stream how I had a backlog
of games and I had a hard time going
through all right I do be like that yeah
it's because I feel like this year
specifically had so many William and
there were so there were so many good
ones too oh yeah after dark yeah this
Court is not the best
I um I spent a lot of time trying to
like complete games like all the way
like 100% 100% right no hard do that it
really is and I took the majority of my
time like I really wanted to play a
bunch of games that were on my backlog
but I did platinum Seki row over the
break which I was extremely proud of
game of the year
it was Game of the Year in Ritchie and I
did a stream before we left for the 2019
right yeah
and like I'm mobbed 3 like New Game+ for
about an hour and a half and I like kind
of got that that like trigger for it
again yeah brightness is pretty pretty
up there isn't it a little more contrast
the body is there like washed out
against the building just blending in
and that's the new type of camera
armyman and they would have put me in
jail by the fire in their lives
mark says honestly I want to see the
chameleon back
I mean hey yeah and like you're looking
at it right like I'm like seeing I saw
them stick out behind each other like
[Laughter]
[Music]
you should
the team is definitely like alright I
think I'm a hangout over and baby seems
like a nice hot zone spices there
Oh God Oh as a floating tag I was like
that was rough I feel like when I play
Cod games I'm just looking for movement
and then that's it
like if something moves I'm like shoot
at it so there's the second you look
away someone's like to the bank write
down an alley - like a I know terrified
boom sick guys are catching up
oh no the window I was trying to use the
post to hide it from that guy and the
guy in the window nozzle I didn't it's
like I can't even bring myself to camp
in a game a little Ryan no I have to
pick stuff up oh those
shoot them honey
show yourselves cowards hey yeah letting
your UK team leader down tied for the
second-most yeah 12 kills and 10 scores
that's pretty close I think I had 14
kills and 4 scores link contributed
level 25 or one level closer it again
pointman is that when you unlock that uh
oh yeah is this the newest Cod yes it is
thank you spy sometimes you just have to
hope that they run where you're firing
and sometimes they do it's pretty great
see pop Jake makes a valid point as this
mode eliminates the point of camping
except some people still camp and then
make their team lose because they're not
contributing no tags they don't get the
concept objective games yeah for real
it's like yeah if you play any sort of
like control objective or you're trying
to like get these capture points and see
someone they've got like 30-something
kills but they have like zero captures
and it's like how many PC players we
have in this Lobby hang on
do that you're old in your own against
those PC rules man most PC players
should be ashamed of themselves I tried
playing on PC too and I'm like I love
peace of shooters but it's just it's a
different beast than it really is
destiny PC I'm perfectly fine with but
any other shooter I just like I always
lose those one with one be ones Oh
vacances back why hello old friend
how are you you lookin a little cleaner
than before this is definitely a nicer
version it's like RPS
I was spraying and praying like running
and said the cod pros don't like this I
wonder why I felt like old folk lawyers
is wrong with my holy moly that was your
bank account I'm kind of just hovering
over those area and people delivery tags
people love Todd the first week then
it's all hate the Pacific firstly no
one's good so it's like it's no one's
good everyone's good and it's height
right height but I still I don't know I
I love like kind of unwinding with God
sometimes
plug in for like 45 minutes or something
to get a few rounds it's like a couple
people and seed gratulate just life's
audience like for instance like this
oh nice I forgot that was a dead-end
hallway
oh look all those tags are you know it's
in such a bad spot
yeah
I didn't see that guy through the gate
there Oh Sheamus he has so many tags
that's all I do
no because he's stuck it out yes
gorgeous Oh
just kidding you're on your own kid yeah
[Applause]
you thought
oh I see let me mess up the spawn by
running around having us me is one of
the best card it's very well done they
kind of made it more or they made it
less random in terms of like I feel like
in the older ones I can like hit you in
the heel once and it might kill you yeah
this one not so much you have to be a
little bit more calculated I think
that's why I may be old school Cod pros
don't like it because it takes too long
to kill somebody
yeah it gets closer to like I mean not
that much closer but closer like hey
well territory where you're like you
have this amount of life and like your
shields and stuff like that
see that's my territory I'm all about
that stuff we're like you have a chance
kind of someone shooting you in the back
yeah where is this I mean you do have
more of a chance I'd be trying to
maneuver walk in serpentine patterns
serpentine patterns I like that that's
that's the pro strat right there hello
Saba how's it goin Abby says to me this
is one of the best got very well done
I'm using an m4 but man so much for me
it's less about the guns and more about
the scopes that make me feel comfortable
I want to unlock the good gun so it's
definitely a classic I think it's mainly
the one I was using in the beta it
mm-hmm but to be fair I love me some gun
fight so you don't really have to choose
your gun and they just give you a random
one you just keep going through it right
that's a fun way to level up guns it is
unless you've your stuff I'm like a
stupid you know like really low firing
or just some gun you're not good with
and then you're always stuck on that
level
let's have gunfight gum game for two
separate things all right I'm tired of
going that way I'm getting bodied let's
switch it up here
I wasn't expecting them to turn around
so fast to be honest when I play out
like run a little bit so I get a better
that's always frustrating I'm just
getting caught in like two different
directions before you can get your
bearings we're a little spread out so I
think the sponsor yeah freaking right
now you didn't even pick up mice what a
loser
oh I was like I'm gonna hope that was
the homie yeah you guys got a commanding
lead right now Deena - Jesus oh these
guys just aren't paying their tags
exactly he's out here in the back of the
spawn by himself there's only two
captains
slack off it goes Cod youtubers have
been complaining dude cut out cod and
just put youtubers have been complaining
[Music]
you have to ask yourself are they
actually upset or they just upset so
they can like get the like' and
subscribe' tag on right like hate has a
very funny way of being more gravitating
than anything
there's a lot going on right now
Oh
too much going on definitely too much
going on I could not compute my brain it
gave up I'm on xbox actually the cool
thing about Cod now is that it's
cross-platform so it doesn't really
matter
he said PS work comp and I thought he
was saying competitive I was like ps4
away yeah we're playing on xbox which
for shooters if you were to compare the
consoles I prefer Xbox over no I stopped
I saw that money won yeah yeah I prefer
yeah I do like the Xbox controller I
like that the left analog stick is in a
more comfortable position for me
personally I feel like my thumb starts
tire out after a while yeah
although and I know you're a fighting
game aficionado and you use the actual
like yeah the fight stick the fight
stick but uh I use a controller for
fighting games and I have to say I feel
a lot better with PS workers cuz I like
the clean Chad is there rather than the
joystick yeah
all right I guess I don't even know
somewhere that's Wow he wasted the whole
clip scared or no I saw him but then I
saw the guy who's that yeah
guys probably still all the way in the
back
I wanted that tag I thought it important
s'more recoiling yourself oh you would
okay man son of a bee I know I don't
know man I'm not the type of player who
likes going to that very far out skirt
behind a rock and just waiting
that's why I give body things game so
much because I'm constantly running
around piccata Lee in the bone with the
bridge or the worst maps yeah they're
they're kind of not great aren't there
they totally I don't mind I know I know
it's like the mean now for Todd but the
bridge one that never liked oh come on
I might try to switch to a better then
make a better class oh yeah I got the
kill though right
like we haven't quite lockdown you guys
have the game in a comfortable it only
goes up to why or is it a time limit
reach yeah so 65 20 20 is gonna be
awesome
yes it is it will be a Happy New Year
Jimmy and I correct I'm so curious to
see like yeah I got body bagging I'm
just curious to see what games they come
out with this year that's gonna like top
last year as a whole you know last year
was pretty good
Deveney that you're excited for it you
kind of know I definitely want to check
out cyberpunk oh yeah for sure
I'm really really curious that's what me
this is that gonna come out before e3 or
after e3 I don't even remember it feel
like it was like a summer release I want
to say like April or something hmm
cyberpunk Scott cyberpunks got the hype
for sure that's gonna be there and then
final fantasy remake Final Fantasy big
Last of Us - oh it's gonna be huge
there's a lot of great games and then of
course the new consoles man oh yeah Xbox
series XPS 5 and like god III this
year's gonna be nuts I don't want to
think about it
Raynor Hernandez asked what's the game
gonna be tomorrow for community Fridays
good question I actually I'm not sure I
could probably ask John Luke later but
you should definitely tune in because
they always got something was always a
big fun in the store I need that one I
think my favorite community Friday is
last year
thinking back because I'm in a
reflective mood uh yeah was the crash
nitro Kart the remaster yeah it was it
was Nick and he was challenging people
to beat him and he was just bodying
people left and right I mean absolutely
destroying people it was unreal and like
the whole office like tuned in like we
were all like working and then we're
also just like okay we got to see Nick
like completely Oh guys so much yeah all
right unfortunately and I my guns are
leveled up enough but we're gonna try
our best yeah trying to level this one
up a little bit sorry I know that was
bad but all right then get my thumb
warmed up
I don't want to pick down the door see
in the old cuts he would have been bit
oh no with this map it's all good
it'll take me a couple times running
around this building I just want to be
in here oh that's really so slow a lot
of nothing over there movies he liked
these whole clip he knew I wanted to tag
that's dangerous I guess I guess our
spawn switched I didn't even realize it
staircase yeah one because someone was
shooting me but I thought I made it
across yeah exactly
oh man it always takes me a few tries on
a new map to like myself gotta find a
good spot good area to hold down
Oh God
why are you up there
boy you gotta collect tags in this game
oh are you serious three tags out there
the ones I collected I got to be smart
about this I just tried to lift and
secure my back
I don't get what's the point of camping
yeah and I have a website but we're
definitely getting bodied still even
with half their team champions oh I did
not see that staircase or the first exam
all right let's see going to attempts
the old jumper
[Music]
busy one thing that I think people don't
like about this is they really kind of
changed the way the guns or with all the
perks certain perks to make aiming down
sight you know worse
little things like bullet drop up like
all the attachments kind of drastically
didn't like look how slow that is some
of the other setups you know like a
faster 80s where I don't have no idea oh
wait it was a shank okay I was like I
don't see him but yeah like since I have
a credit alone it's super slow iron
sights are a little bass
okay honestly people are probably
camping because they have pointman and
they're like I'll just get these noise
someone knocks it down another people
I love going to the like death cam and
it's just them one extraordin yeah
like this mofo yeah it again enemy in
the cosmic that's one thing I like
though nothing you guys they have that
character is kind of call it out for you
yeah they let you know well you don't
have people ok this Aleph is camping or
chopper so break you okay yeah we're
getting destroyed
and honestly just like stack up all
those posters unleashing it it's cuz
everyone's trying to deliver a
killstreak so they're just camping get
the chopper she died thank goodness
tried to jump by this bag go so high a
little
poor says there any ka on VR you mean
Battle Royale
I don't think there is gonna be a
battleground or everything yeah I think
God was kind of like their focus
honestly yeah between like for tonight
and a big I'm so bad I'm so bad
that's your first load out right yeah
you're killing it with that one yeah I
tried to use that other gun for like one
whole life I hate when I stop shooting
because I think oh yeah yeah they're
like nope um freaking Superman here yes
sometimes you have to forget about all
times
[Music]
and literally confirmed the fear
gosh gosh oh the D phone I thought it
was a B+ red Oh was it be fault
see this is probably why I wouldn't play
this mode because now like people are
just going for all the kills right and
the game's going on forever like until
time limits I'm delivering anything
that's that is a downfall for it that's
downfall with the most objective oh man
I'm like I just wanted to be overall
radio they would just select the damn
tags when I was reading the blog post
for them bringing this game back they
were definitely like oh it's gonna be so
hard to stay alive for a long time in
this game mode it's like yeah if you're
playing the objective yeah yeah that was
rough Oh shine goes the actual see he
has an m4 I wish they showed which
attachment areas and actually like their
loadout no that would be a lot of words
though okay but look at the guy
underneath you you only have to like
look what is he doing
we did have a ton of PC players in that
Lobby it sounds you can change it though
let me see you can you can you can um
it's for cross play right oh yeah
why don't I switch it to you're just
gonna dude you're gonna write I thought
they had its where you can still play
with people who are on PC but if they're
playing a controller I want to say that
that's kind of it like if you get
matched up with the PC players might
default it's they're using the
controller almost by mistaken
now I ever game we've had so far it had
like PC icon with the mouse icon okay
but it's all good
it kind of comes with the territory it
be like that sometimes searching for a
match I just looking on those daily
challenges I'm trying to see like battle
paths even worth it to kind of go
through all those all the challenges and
gather up those XPS this seems like
you're unlocking two different things
you're locking your regular weapons and
perks and things like that and then the
battle paths I'm assuming is just
cosmetic yeah like you just get I think
you get like some special guns that you
can get like blueprints for and you can
build them GZ ghosts don't discriminate
fighters we're not I'm not I can't kill
this on a controller I will say though
which is also really hilarious to me is
that I've been seeing like PC players
complain about a misis on controller I'm
like you got to be pretty bad if you can
complain about that as a PC player but
cuz yeah it's there but it's not so much
that it's gonna be like lopsided for the
person on a mouse and a keyboard right
Q&Y min it's still possible to miss
horribly with amesys we saw it last game
yeah that's all right
hey it's everyone's favorite map cuddly
yeah it's it's the one that like
everyone hates cuz it's it's pretty
close I okay I personally don't hate it
I think it's could it be better yeah but
I don't think it
live TV h TV alright we're gonna see the
one that's from like the campaign mode
yes did play this part in a campaign but
I did not I played in one - Blair yeah
yeah I'm gonna lie running into all
these dead ends
yeah man let's get those sneakers got a
copy
the hell is everyone I hate perspire
juice okay I don't mind them but it
takes me a while to like get used to the
bursts especially I don't have anything
attached to this either so no work no
barrels and anything paralyzers oh all
that jumping oh yeah and he's using me
um yeah I don't think I can do a burst
right now either not going well
I just want to find somebody
all right
I saw the icon and did absolutely
nothing about it oh I think that's yeah
I don't think so
unless that person dies oh yeah it is
huh I think they should female equipment
on the map yeah shoddy is really good
clothes
Oh God being I changed that class I
think that I had a shotgun secondary it
might be a better choice right now
didn't really how close quarters that
the I did change that that's new but
they always believe someone defaults I
have oh I am here like so me all cracks
and crevices they could hear oh I know
what I can do
oh god yeah I was like this guy's over
here is the freaking I'll get you're
just gonna claim wear it up see they he
got us both there's only two rounds in
that jacket you blasted us venom count
okay let me formulate a plan here I
don't want to go in there anymore so I'm
just gonna have to seal it off did you
probably any get one or unless he hops
over oh my god I really got exploded by
the dang cars my luck today
my
I couldn't even deliver one zag I just
never want yes danger zone yeah except
there's another version here you
actually pushed out people don't play
like how they used to that's why because
you do have more life together okay I
okay to brush out like that back in the
day
[Music]
please
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't know if that even landed I was
like did I accidentally put that on the
roof after like
we switch on the new Oh God
like 30 tags wait a well man All Things
Considered that was like I was
definitely a child blue brands are
special mods for bait of base weapons IC
required the battle yeah I was like I
think they had something that just makes
the guns better I almost never the less
room yeah you're on the come up man I
know it's this it's a slow and steady
incline just not feeling my gun right
now but I should it's this is my only
well level depends I probably have
better stuff or Han goes is the
environment look unrealistic because of
two bright colors or is it just me well
we we were in tissues yeah you know we
were lowered the brightness a little bit
but I think just by nature the games
pretty pastel II right which is a bad
thing I think it's a pretty cool
aesthetic to be honest
all right hold up I need that I need to
get out of this search real quick China
trying to soup up yeah I'm struggling
with this slow down so yeah let's uh
clear all these out
I need faster 80s so I'm gonna try not
to put anything on there that's gonna
ruin that mm-hmm these all ruin that I I
thought I saw some that said it was
faster aim-down-sights what could be
mistaken yeah it's this barrel here yeah
and a deer sniper is by far my favorite
blueprint deer sniper was fun in the
campaign that was a was a really fun gun
fifty round mags why is that
remove 80s Oh cause it's heavier I guess
that makes more sense that makes life
sense I suppose
[Music]
Isaac's going we haven't unlocked more
attachments it yeah we're only level
like hard on the beta almost 26 yeah I'm
already cool hold up I kind of want
sleight-of-hand zone
what's that do faster swapping it seeing
the gun and say like yeah are faster
reload I'll let him see me come at me
bro
all right and for this one Oh actually I
want to have a shoddy secondary because
that seems to be the wave we're working
out so hold on it down this bad way out
says everything she is its own prick so
now I got a level is up rip yeah
extra rest in pieces all right let's try
that one out let's do it oops too far
please be okay every time I accidentally
back out of the lobby I get so scared
it's not gonna work nothing saves all
right all right right definitely need
that 80s I was like I'm always slowing
the draw and then they're just already
there destroying me they get the first
shot out and they just let it sit so
even though I only have one item that
ups my 80s no at least it's better than
nothing I took off the perks that were
slowing me down so yeah I think you
pointed it out too I noticed you're like
very slow just like kind of dramatic we
exaggerated as you're going to aim down
yeah yeah just like it's kind of a
bummer 20 hip fire kills note it you
probably get those with that Ravens
asking grind mode yes see you later
Brandon yeah grind mode it's it's an old
new mode like it's a new to modern
warfare here but it's been in a couple
old Cod games and it's a mix between
Kill Confirmed and hard points you gotta
like deliver your tags to the hardpoint
pretty much
yeah it's been pretty ham I feel like if
you're strictly going after objective
you're just gonna get clipped by the
people camping and farming killstreaks
but if you went in with a full squad I
can see this being very fun right like
have your two designated campers and
then you know people guiding the dude
yeah two designated campers I love that
you just be the one like the two people
everyone's gonna hate you know yeah and
then the rest of your team just like
cashes in on it I love it absolutely do
it man that one map that's like square
and then it has like the inside
courtyard with the fountain I just love
the big put up whatever y'all let me out
no this doesn't look like
right reven asks can you level up faster
with your ground node I don't know if
there's like a faster way to do it I'm
not sure how the points compared yeah I
know it's more of like you getting more
kills or if it's going through matches
you know quicker don't know hey man
that's that's the gut instinct you gotta
go with area I knew I was like I bet
she's on the bright side the 50/50 I
hate it know that first I didn't get one
shot on him you get extra XP if you
stack 5 tags before the bank the old
mega bank alright I didn't realize that
so many one of our new moves in this
game they've been adding him in for sure
hey you got him on the hot love it holy
moly you know what let me just deliver
this before it's too late and for good
measure I was like i'ma jump over this
ledge and someone's gonna be up there
but it was my teammate so we're doing
shots we have the beetle for one hiding
inside of this house did not like ya
sorry Stan
all right
see you try to get out of that building
[Music]
that's where I saw bullet fly by my face
who I'm dead I'm a running shoes on
that's not a door I gotta grab that tag
though oh yeah Killman
someone out here mowing down this one I
thought he was like further away oh yeah
I look lame or as those are my best
friends right they they give me peace of
mind they may not be working out well on
this map at the moment we out only got
three of them but yeah the other homie
definitely you like to sauna fied
exactly what I did
and an obvious fondant
wallbang yeah I was like I can shoot
through this Sony's going nice one nice
gameplay I'm glad you tuned in during
this game and none of the other ones I
was playing cuz they're all trash this
is like the first time I'm actually
contributing I also think that is it's
also a part it's like the team is doing
really well
this will have 20 noodles and 28 scores
I also turned off cross please so that
might also affect damn look at you 2.0
KD even Ellen says this is the first
time he's watching and it's enjoying the
stream well thank you happy new year Oh
3,800 XP but I will say after adjusting
some of my perks and attachments it's
better it's way better it's better now
for sure but yeah the other team did get
destroyed not because of me but hey man
you're doing your no I hate this map I'm
sorry I can't do it which mouth was that
it was that oops
was that rosna raid1 it's just so it was
in the beta I didn't like it much it was
very candy which you know obviously I'm
still getting camped out but a lot of
these other maps are kind of close
quarters
whereas graha it's only close quarters
in certain areas and into those areas
got to go through like these stretches
of like open streets and soften I never
farewell paranoia inducing yeah
like like there's always a sniper
somewhere on the other side of the
street getting shot on the back it's
like ah I'm telling you guys give me a
moment man the pure like paranoia behind
thinking everyone somewhere hmm what's
true it feels that way most of the time
blacks I guess I'm on all the new games
me too man
you and me both bro I want all the new
games as well I am excited for the
Kingdom Hearts DLC what is that coming
out supposedly this month like in 21
days it's like a story DLC I think so it
being is called like remind or something
like that but they showed footage of
like playable Kairi and that's enough to
get me that's really I actually just
started playing Kingdom March 3 like
literally two days ago I played it when
it came out and then I had other games
that I had to cover for work so I got
distracted but like I love Kingdom
Hearts you know it was playing the whole
series beforehand so this is really
exciting
yeah I know I saw a lot of people like
cuz I've only completed it recently too
and before then obviously I'd been out
for like almost a whole year by that
point but everybody was like it's so bad
it's so bad so bad 13 harshly yes
everything is bad so after playing it I
definitely feel like the story was
lacking but the graphics and the
gameplay gosh it was beautiful so the
story is so far from where I am I mean
it's still a little confusing like every
Kingdom Hearts game tends to be but like
I don't mind it and I remember our own
some more who saying who did the review
right he was saying how any part of like
organization 13 and that storyline he
didn't care for
he liked the donald goofy goofy is my
favorite so that's the thing I'm on top
Simon I love the organization my anime
PS like I love that stuff yeah I mean
time so I'm here for it but um
I think he had a Oh shield that like
protects I'm still reactive man luckily
he was weakened there were complaints
about I am bad he was already weak and
thank goodness I wasn't say people were
complaining on Cod for a little bit
about the the shield like people were
just running around with shields for the
longest time I mean when you got clean
words and like bouncing Betties I was
like is that a guy the decision-making
was so surreal that someone left the
game already know she loved that man
they just like oh this isn't my game and
they just barely I feel like this is my
looking oh sick where you can find out
pretty really if it is gonna be yeah
no whole teams there and then you got
the homie in the back
[Music]
see if you actually shot someone at that
range like oh dude there's so many
people bro you got a bang oh no way I
think they killed mine saying I was
betting man why do I have no patience of
it I might as a way to like a split
second longer every time later marks
thanks for tuning in
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah so they were both in two separate
queries everyone's just talking over on
that honestly they're this far ahead
because that can we get to attack
but that was such a gift that was like
I'm not even gonna read cuz I know
where is that another beetle my life oh
my god oh I'm still so sad about those
tags
follow me
Oh silly friends I am beyond
and I he just flew away that's the
moment where you like change your
loadout to the one with the rock if you
like one yeah you're like dude I can't
hear anyone's feet I rely on that so
much oh no we're not
yeah they're literally just waiting like
that's the real tax it's yeah I feel
like it's gotta be a way to move got a
let's get B now it's just funny like I
feel like in this game you could try so
hard to like play well and like you know
be mobile and then you could kill by
that guy crouching in a corner yeah
are you just getting like caught in two
different directions and Dave the Beast
is level five so you know he doesn't
have anything dude
that's the other crying dude that's the
other grind to this game getting
everything what Cod's like pots having a
seizure I know it's like that's a great
you sure you want to keep playing you're
not doing too hot
yeah that's some good rounds man you had
some fun kills yeah
I mean for me cops always been that game
where I'm like all right let me just
level up spin a good chunk of time just
leveling up and then getting a good like
better loadout with all the perks and
like all the options that you know it
takes a while
Laurens asking about the na T type
because it's moderate yeah we do have
really good internet here but it is also
corporate so there's a lot of securities
yeah and things like that so I notice in
here specifically it's always not
moderate yeah it's usually I'll moderate
yeah that might work desk it's always on
strict too so I have to like yeah see me
you get paired up with people who have
to have open n 80s for things to work
but it works fine the download the
download and upload speeds are really
really stellar so oh my gosh I remember
the headaches gnat types used to be
you'd have to do some crazy stuff to
open those ports and everything come on
please don't give me grass Nereid like
for the last map that's all I asked I
really honestly I just need to be more
patient I'm kind of playing it like I
would play TDM or something I just run
around line yeah you know what that one
map on over watches the like
egyptian-themed map I don't remember the
name I haven't played overwatch in a
while like picturing it though I just
remember the there's a moment cuz you
were saying please don't give me that
one map right and I was thinking about
this one time when I was playing comp
and just this guy who was in team chat
kept chanting like please don't be like
arch please don't be arched please don't
be arch and then it just like the map
shows itself as some other guy and like
a really exhausted voice is just like
its arch well you you freakin doomed us
man like you know jinx it absolute jinx
which map was this our favorite picanha
Lee okay the one with your claymores
between the busses yeah let's go oh man
I have my shotty now let's yeah yeah
give it up give it a give it a try
this is the game guys this is the game
see like 151 you know he has all the
goodies one hundred and thirteen hundred
twenty three one day you ever seen that
one mean where it was like my game
collection as a kid and like a stack and
then it's like my getting collection now
I'm just like maybe three or four yeah
yeah yeah now you go to like your game
section on your console where like games
owned 93 installed ten exactly ball is
base you got on your Asian although the
new consoles are gonna I think they're
defaults like one terabyte at least I
feel like that needed to be a thing now
yeah for sure like we should be looking
into the two terabyte face now to tbh
although I don't know if they will
because then they have a good market
what's selling the oh yeah knives and
they make them game themed so you have
like a Gears of War hard drive yeah you
know things like that the sea gates fair
so it would make sense for them but it
is gonna be SSDs so who's loading times
are gonna be like non-existent which is
funny noise its 2020 it's about time
daddy
loading screens how dare you
all right
let's hope for the best man who dropped
off on the heli up to 75% off the Black
Friday sale we're ready oh gosh it's so
far though that I don't trust it's like
the long range fight got your sister
avens layer grinding is hard for me in
mono worker I just get shotguns ya know
I've been struggling too good it's
definitely it's a different kind of game
type it definitely forces you to play
differently really really weird is that
Modern Warfare hustle bro run around too
much Danny see 20/20 give us one tara i
standard a word what's up to you as well
Shamari
hi pop Jake thanks for tuning in man go
charge your phone
[Music]
I will see I kind of struggled with
Miami or like using the sound to figure
out where people are yeah it's it's not
as a
gravattack
I didn't see him through the tag and it
was like kind of smoky there too never
event of Kill Confirmed itself though
but I do enjoy
like my thoughts on Modern Warfare maps
so far that's a good question because
obviously I really enjoy a lot of the
returning Maps sure and some of the
newer ones I just feel like there's a
lot a lot of places to be and you can
keep track of all of them he's so far to
and I want to run all the way over there
and die Oh
I just heard man was he spine oh yeah it
was like he was getting shot at and he
was like nah I don't care I'm getting
shot at
I'm just gonna keep on Amy seriously
it's also hard to know that's a play
more and you scream
[Music]
oh I gotta get out of here
the objective is literally too hard and
you get to sit there in camp and wait
for someone to deliver tags it's mostly
heart I just delivered that guy like
five times
trying it to the gate
ha when I'm out in the open like oh this
guy he was out in the open crouching
just like with no cover no one shoots at
him
nothing happened I run out for a second
like Eagle Eye
oh boy oh boy oh thank you guys sitting
in a corner put a claymore down and dive
in attacks on that random input claim
there's just a bunch of claim more
deaths man setting it all up for
disaster guys like you can get away with
sniping like that because it takes
longer to kill people now like you can
eat a few shots I wish I could get away
we can't be like that
[Music]
and I reload noise you're so fixated on
on that party damn it takes more hits to
die in this Cod than probably any other
cut that's been out oh maybe that's not
you're the last one was with kind of
this similar path alright let's see if
my camping works out here
not the theme guy oh he had a yeah I was
like you definitely should have been low
enough for me and going but he's going
for a sailor someone is here there's
explosions everywhere
Oh Lord where
I'm always like just so happen to have
my back turned at home zero which is
really funny it's just my orange look at
the drawer I tried to stay like towards
the outskirts
I ran into their spawn so bad
[Music]
so hard I'm too objective focus it's hot
this is a hard game mode for me
personally just gonna sit because it
requires a certain place yeah it's tough
you know yeah I keep forgetting to use
my stopping power last time I tried to
use it the second I reloaded it into my
clip I died did you keep doing
significantly better than the majority
of your team though it was like like
you're always at least in top three it's
just alright it's alright alright well
is that was stressful yeah that was
stressful but it is just not my type of
game mode which is fine it's fun for me
I just get it back just like hey over
there yeah I mean I think my favorite
game mode so far in this game is
probably gunfight gunfights one you know
less people like two one two you got one
life for a round really comes down to
like the gunplay instead of like oh snap
I'm in a good hiding spot just like
killing these people running by me or
something it's all good I think it
probably is a good mode for people
trying to level up because you know I
wasn't really even doing that well and I
was still getting like a couple okay
like XP every time yeah for sure yeah
there you have you guys if you enjoy
yourself some kill confirm slash
hardpoint definitely check out the new
game-mode it's out now shoot house 24/7
is also out now I kind of just want to
see I'm not gonna go into the game I
just wanna see if this is the same oh no
way it's not I think the one on Cod
Mobile's called kill house but yeah I'll
check that out later
anywho thank you guys so much for tuning
in I hope you have an amazing day yeah
beginning explaining 20 is here don't
forget i'm persia yeah persia it's even
you know this is how you know we're
starting new york really switch news
it's all good
anywho thank guys so much for tuning in
and we will be live every weekday at 11
a.m. pacific so please tune in thank you
guys so much and have a good one okay
yes